When we talked about configuration, we alluded to design.
Design is a very wide ranging, open ended activity. But then we settled on to
configuration, very routine kind of design, where all the parts of the design
are already known, we simply have to figure out the configuration of the parts.
It is time now to return to design thinking. What is design thinking?
Design thinking is about thinking about ill-defined, underconstrained,
open ended problems. Let's a design a house that is sustainable is an example of
design thinking. Sustainability here is ill-defined. The problem is open ended.
In design thinking, it is not just that a solution that evolves,
it is that the problem it was as well. We have problem, solution, coevolution.